I threw up
you know it's a one mile run with a boat
on your head I threw up for a mile and a
little bit because we ran all the way to
the Oak course and we did the oak course
with our boat and I threw up all the way
through that of course hauling the boat
around and then I've got no fuel in the
tank uh that was a long long day yeah I
remember that you know and then remember
the other things about you know the
housing is a you know hallucinating you
know you know Lion's lope you know the
uh you know getting mad at my paddle I
remember it though because my paddle's
not you know you know making us go I'm
crying hard you know that this paddle
should make me go faster you know uh
yeah remembering paddle prayers you know
uh what's battle prayers so they would
put us together around in a circle oh
this weird paddle above the other guy's
head you got your paddle yeah you got
your paddle so you're like this and when
you fall asleep you try and catch
yourself and you whack the tooth it's
like is that in the program
yeah uh you know I was a really
motivated young you know a number one
bottom line man you know the guy the guy
that jumps out on the Rock Portage and
neighbors the boat and I wanted to be
that guy you know uh that's the spot man
that's the spot get in there let's do
this and uh when that boat's upside down
on your head uh that's the spot too
because you're taking some serious
weight yeah that's a dangerous evolution
in big waves man you know we didn't have
helmets Yeah you know we had k-pops in a
big giant you know horribly
uncomfortable life jackets uh and uh
wow now they got helmets you know dude I
I noticed they took the Stump Jump
completely out now yeah but they reduced
the stumps first and now the stumps are
all gone and they're tired tires yeah
and that's kind of because that's a
mental thing you know
um everybody knew the right stumps to
jump on
it's just that
all the fear of falling yeah and I don't
remember anybody falling I you know I
don't know that somebody fell and they
hit their head yeah Echo this is on on
the obstacle course one of the first I
guess it was this actually the second
obstacle you go across that dip bar
thing right right and then you'd hop off
and there'd be
telephone poles caught off at various
Heights in the ground like stumps and
you would have to jump from stump to
stump to stump and they'd kind of
increase in Heights and the last one was
a little was depending on which route if
you took the right route which everybody
knew right the last one was the tallest
one had to jump a little bit further for
it and then you could jump you jump up
onto this uh grab this wall this low
wall which was probably like 10 10 feet
tall or something like that from the
stump from the stump but it did take
it did take like uh what's commitment
right commitment to jump from stump to
stump yeah and it got you used to
committing right and now it's Just Tires
like you see on a football field you
know you run the tires oh okay yeah
you're right about that psychological
part right right there's a fear of
falling it's just like you know if you
focus on the the stump that you might
fall on you're not looking at the stump
that you want yeah you know like if
you're or your skiers yeah yeah
um if you ski with a helmet on uh and
then you take your helmet off
there you see you ski slower especially
if you ski in the trees I mean if you're
skiing in the trees and
if you're looking for the gaps you're
good to go if you're looking for the
trees that you don't want to hit you're
going to find that tree yeah you know
and the same kind of thing it's it's a
it's a psychological thing you know to
get you moving forward yep and they got
helmets now too that they wear all the
time which is weird too because like
even during hell week they wear helmets
really which is to me the agony of that
boat grinding on your head was like a
huge part of of what song oh yeah yeah
because you're getting you know your
head you're getting some serious sunburn
you don't have a whole bunch of hair
yeah uh it's yeah your head's getting
blistered it's a psychological part of
it man that that uh
yeah I don't know if I'd want to wear a
helmet or not actually yeah a little
warm you know I don't know any other so
once you got done with how weak you're
in the rest of buds was there any other
major challenges for you there
um eating dry out at the island where'd
you say eat and dry yeah so you know at
at least one meal a day you had to
either do the pull-ups the Frog hill run
or the Rope climb well did you suck at
something pull-ups okay I could not yeah
gravity you know rope climb's fine
because you use your legs technique
um but man I ate wet a lot full of day
uh it was funny because for whatever
reason I never did pull-ups growing up
and uh yeah that was uh no the island
was second phase for me yeah uh that
switched eventually yeah or back to it I
guess so yeah eventually I mean I became
a pull-up freak you know as a big guy
you know I think uh even after my
shoulder surgeries I did you know 26
something pull-ups like six months later
it's like it's personal challenge uh but
uh yeah so so pull-ups was one you know
running not a great Runner you know
swimming but you know you're swimming
you know uh
yeah
not a top performer by any means uh but
just kept going forward you know and uh
you know just all you had to do was
perform you know
um pass you know but perform you know
not tying
um
normally no Factor
we did it in the dive Tower
how deep
well the ropes stay same depth uh 10
feet zinke took me down to 50 feet
and we just hung out there and looked at
each other
and uh until he was you know tired and
then we came up to the top and there is
a set
you know it's all set what you're
supposed to be doing uh and uh
I was like okay yeah you're ready to go
yeah ready to go yeah you know
then we went down and uh and then we
came back up you know and Bam next not
back down again and back up and down no
so I failed that
yeah uh you know that's one thing that's
interesting what I remember about some
of the breath holding stuff like 50
meter underwater swim you're going to
buzz you're like Ah that's no big deal I
could do that but and not tying oh it's
like what's nine feet go down their tie
knot but you're in in buds because of
everything that's going on you're
constantly like beat down so you almost
always have a cough you kind of have a
cold you kind of have like mucus you're
always like that you're always tired
like like a Four Mile time run
Four Mile time run
first phase was 32 minutes Four Mile
time run you look at that on paper on
the outside you're like what's that
that's a freaking you know I could do
that no problem then you get in there
you have boots on you got pants on
you're running in the soft sand and the
run is not four miles it's like 4.2
miles 4.4 miles 4.5 miles right and then
and and what'd you do the night before
the night before that morning four
o'clock in the morning Four Mile time
run you did you know a thousand eight
count bodybuilders so you did Buddy
carries up and down the burn so
everything is harder than it than you
think it's gonna be in buds it's not
what's on paper it's what what actually
happens is harder yeah no and you didn't
get to eat but you had to run to ciao
and you had to go through the line and
touch the hamburger that you want to eat
but there was no time to actually eat it
you know you wasted time running all the
way but you that's what you must go
there to do that but there's no time to
actually sit down and eat and then you
run and you go do the other solution
because you have to be at the evolution
on time